good morning good afternoon good evening
everyone and Happy Hanukkah we are here
back on our countdown for best of the
year 2017 here at GameSpot today we're
gonna be telling you our number seven
game as voted on and argued by the
GameSpot staff I'm Mike my Hardy here
with Peter Brown Santa Claus Kelly foggy
hi and in Nick margarita howdy
and we might as well get right into it
before we start rolling a montage for
number seven I want to reiterate every
day weekday going up until December 20th
we are announcing one more game in our
lineup and then on December 24 having a
mega stream where we'll do three two and
one so you don't just like know what two
and one are the night before but yeah
without much further ado let's check out
number seven of 2017
you think your hero Josephus coach
I got kids on the way and I'll be damned
if I'm gonna raise them in a world run
by these Nazi [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll tell you them got them that's
itself a just coming here we gonna shoot
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so I got a nuke this year fire
extinguisher okay cool it I did not mean
to Riley
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so there you have it Wolfenstein - the
new Colossus by Machine games published
by Bethesda is our number seven game of
the year we have been talking earlier
about how it came out kind of tail end
of the year October 27th with Sasa's
Creed origins and Super Mario Odyssey
that day of death I was actually pretty
fun but yeah it came out the tail end of
Year Kali pluggy you reviewed it you
gave it a 9 out of 10 which a GameSpot
means superb superb tell me in a
nutshell what makes this game on number
7 on our list for me I mean it's a
sequel to 2014 is the new order and as a
sequel it it expands so much on what
that game was trying to do I think it it
balances it's like super bonkers
off-the-wall tone really well with a
more serious like really heavy subject
matter I mean this is not a
light-hearted game by any means but the
tone shifts are constant and yet so
evocative and I also think that the the
gameplay really feeds into that and and
makes you feel like you have the power
to resist against the occupying Nazi
forces yes it's live we are gonna stream
it momentarily we might spoil stuff
later but right now we'll avoid spoilers
but Nick bringing this game to
nazi-occupied America how did that serve
the game did you like going to New
Orleans New York the the environments in
the level design in general yes so this
was a pretty awesome game because of
what we learned in new order you know
there were a lot of newspaper clippings
and kind of information you could find
in the previous game that would give us
an idea of what's going on back in the
United States
mm-hm and so this game finally getting
there and seen like Fallout New York
basically knew it was nuked in the pass
game we just hadn't seen it yet it shows
like how far the Reich is willing to go
in order to like control and have full
power over like the world and so that's
why I think this game is so jarring it
does have its comical moments but when
you go to New York you're like holy cow
like think of how many people died here
it's it's insane
yeah it does shift pretty dramatically
and fluidly I'd say like you know
there's the New Orleans scene they
showed where the guy plays clarinets
like what diegetic music or whatever
what's the word I want to say to sound
smart I think it's dietetic
the music's happening in the scene and
then someone's shooting it not he's out
the window you can see it right here and
then Horton is the resistance contact in
New Orleans and of course you've already
met up with you know like the Black
Panther inspired group in New York which
is pretty cool but Kelly these
characters obviously the new order like
you said was very character-driven but
new Colossus especially I think was
going for that angle as well did you
find that some of these new characters
stuck with you throughout the months
yeah absolutely I think the the best
thing about these characters is that I
mean this character is pretty out there
I think super specials probably the most
like totally insane character in a lot
of ways but no one is just used for
comic relief nobody is is just like a
plot device driving something forward
there's a lot of nuance to the
characters that makes them relatable
even in the fantastical
out-of-this-world aspects of this game
and the new order was I think like that
it but a little less so and more kind of
like a linear story driven I think this
is more like allowing you to really see
into these characters their motivations
why they believe in the resistance and
and what happened each of them they all
have they carry these physical and
mental scars I mean grace has as she was
you know in the nuclear fallout and she
has like a burned hand and stuff like
that and you you get to know them in a
way that makes the story of resistance
more powerful to me yeah Nick the new
order obviously was known for allowing
you to kind of be stealthy or just go
guns blazing dual wielding or like focus
on explosives or a mix of all three or
four they kind of doubled down on that
and new Colossus with the contraptions
do you feel that that approach was still
intact in the new Colossus yeah and I
think those contraptions simply elevated
that and so as someone who likes to go
into the rooms gun blazing having the
RAM shackles was like my favorite thing
in the whole world like the bulrush
right yeah you like run into Nazis they
explode in your path but like really
yeah really
but Kali on the other hand played more
stealthily and so she used the
constrictor and so that allows you to go
through pipes and be more stealthy
around the environment and I think that
changes the way you play the game and
really good ways but it still keeps like
the themes that were so awesome in new
order like all the weapons and we get
new weapons in new Colossus we get new
ways to play I think it was it was a
perfect way to make a good step in the
right direction in terms of a video game
sequel right driving it forward internal
T Kelly did you find that it was pretty
well paced in that respect throughout
the game I see the thing is I wouldn't
say it's well paced but I think that's a
positive right so I mean this is there's
a lot of difficulty spikes in this game
there's a lot of really challenging
moments even on the bring them on I
think is the default difficulty and
that's like three in a list of six even
on that difficulty there's times where I
was like alright I got this I figured it
out I figured out how to kill all these
Nazis and then I would you know the
there's like a courtroom scene that's
just halfway through the game and you're
like this has to be the ending cuz this
is so freaking hard and I think that at
least from my point of view and how I
interpreted the game that enhanced my
feeling of powerlessness in a lot of
ways I felt like I was really overcoming
something almost impossible when I
fought against the Reich and I felt like
the the difficulty the almost like
throwing yourself against this wall that
is nearly impenetrable helps enhance the
feeling of like yes this was this is
worth doing even though we all are
getting hopeless this was something that
needed to be done and was hard fought
and it avoids feeling like a power
fantasy because of that yeah you feel
like they they were right to stick to
their guns with non regenerating health
you have to pick up health packs you
have to pick up ammo manually most of
time although sometimes will happen
automatically ammo yeah it was like kind
of inconsistent or was there allotted to
it I didn't understand
no I noticed that too yeah it was
sporadic sometimes the time if you took
down like panzer hoon and you like
walked over it you would pick up the
armor but if there was armor on a shelf
you would have to physically walk like a
place to any environment yeah it has
like a logic to it yeah you like the
old-school feel I guess the mechanics
here if that's the right way to phrase
it
Komi
a chance to really play this game as
much as I wanted to you're like I'm the
unlucky one on set who just didn't get
the opportunity so you'll have to ask
them
we're playing the one we're announcing
tomorrow quite a lot yes
but we also got the chance to you know a
well this game allows you to go back
with the Intel missions and try out like
it's actually like really to drastically
changes some areas if you go back to
this certain ranch or the certain place
in New York and you can kind of hunt
down specific officers and everything
it's so smart to have those Intel
missions like new order didn't have
anything like that so not only is it
like oh there's more for me to play like
there's more to this game it's also like
your work is not done your work is not
done because you you beat the big bad
you know yeah well speaking of obviously
we won't spoil exactly what happens but
how do you feel
they're not it's weird to like call them
boss fight you fight Mecca death's-head
in new order right you can kind of
assume there'd be some sort of huge
fights or boss fights or encounters in
this game how do you think they handled
those without spoiling it like this game
there's a really really good job of
hiding those battles whereas you knew
kind of especially at the end of new
order you knew okay this is the boss
battle that's gonna end the game in new
Colossus it does a really really good
job
kind of disguising these boss battles
that kind of bookend this specific
chapters in each kind of area that
you're in mm-hmm but I never really felt
like oh man like this is it this is the
boss battle and then I move on to the
next one yeah there was always a sense
of like uncertainty about like wow that
was really hard like I wonder what's
gonna be thrown at me next and is there
still more I need to do here and it is
always kind of like in the back of your
mind yeah and also it was like very good
at still allowing you to take whatever
approach you want to get through these
skirmishes I say yeah and I think that
as far as the level design goes with the
three contraptions that you get halfway
through the game it is very easy to read
which direction you're encouraged to go
to with each contraption but I think
overall the level design allows for
freedom she likes which your approach
halfway through you're like I mean even
in this clip I didn't even plan this you
saw like oh I'm just gonna like shoot
from a room and
it's just going like balls to the wall
so I absolutely love when shooters can
kind of convey the character in the way
that they fight and Wolfenstein new
order and even more so in new cloths
it's so great at how like just bombastic
and messy BJ is like he's not that
accurate I mean the guns aren't
inaccurate on purpose some of them are
though they're really like unwieldy
almost and then you're just it feels
like he's just pissed yeah I love it
it's like it's like destiny all the guns
and the characters feel fluid yeah yeah
especially hunters but like this feels
like it's a pissed-off
American soldier just like wants to kill
Nazis in his country yeah and it just
kind of revs you up the whole time even
the hatchet kills or like so and like
that's the thing is you'd think it's
like ah gory like our fighting Vera but
it's very much like you get his emotions
especially because it's kind of talking
to himself not in a way that's like
annoying to me he's kind of like
ruminating on what he's doing but he
just he hates them so much and he just
goes for it and you you're right you do
really like the actual movement conveys
that even between stealth and guns
blazing and everything else in terms of
the game to the variety of different
ways you can kill and dismember Nazis is
just mind-boggling how many different
animations there are for like this one
like okay
got some are you laughing like you it is
it's so satisfying oh yeah yeah as sick
as that might sound to some people it's
so sad no the game mechanically feels it
feels flawed on purpose in a good way
the actual the feel of it and I think
they nailed it specifically but through
and through after laughter that's coming
up been out for like two months now Nick
what are some of that what's like in
broad strokes what are the things that
like stuck with you and made you argue
for this and vote for this on our top 10
of the year so I fought for this game
pretty hard and I think the reason why I
was fighting for it was for its story
and its narrative more so than its
gameplay
I think its gameplay took the great
things that it had in new order and
pushed it in new Colossus
but this story every moment we were like
wow like I wonder how far they're going
to push it whether its backstory or just
the craziness of what the Nazis
been able to achieve in that day and age
you're like how far can the story push
and then it just goes beyond anything
you could ever imagine or come up so I
mean shout out to all the writers that
worked on this game because they stopped
giving a [ __ ] like two hours ago yeah
and it was just surprised after surprise
after surprise yeah yeah finally
catching up everybody who didn't have a
chance to play all ten games yeah
there's still some ones that I have to
play but yeah I'm right there with you
neck like the I think you could argue
and like I alluded to it the like a
level design that's pretty the
Telegraph's kind of where it wants you
to go I think you could like there were
some people who were saying like I don't
see how it pushes the shooter genre
forward and I strongly disagree with
that and that's one of the things I
fought for is I think as far as like the
narrative goes and how the gameplay
interacts with that narrative is is is a
really big step for shooters I mean I've
never ever played a game with Black
Panthers in it first of all like I
thought I mean that that could seem like
a small thing but I think that's a
really really huge statement that
machine games made with this game where
they were like oh yeah and like PJ is
not even the leader grace is the leader
and she's the one who tells you what the
[ __ ] you're supposed to do because like
she has these principles and you're just
there to be her muscle like it's I I
think narrative Lee it does so many
important things for the genre that I
really believe in grace she's also like
when she's not killing us she's taking
care of her baby she's breastfeeding
like oh there's like a breastfeeding C
in this game there's there's so much
there's so much I wasn't expecting
that's like not at all or herself is
pregnant throughout this game that's
like a no thing right from the beginning
- yeah pregnant and like throwing
grenade wheeling guns yeah it's never
it's never like oh don't go out because
we want to protect you and your pregnant
body it's more like well we loved you
and I want you to live but also like we
kind of do need you to do this it's also
genuinely funny at some parts like when
you're when BJ a birthday parties so
that's really good too but when BJ it's
like in the game like while you're right
after you kill a few Nazis BJ will say
something to Anya Anya will be like yeah
I just killed a few kind of liking it
and then it's like becomes this like
sexual moment between the two and then
they're like wait is this channel open
and then I think it's like anyway but
yeah this game like between the writing
the momentum of carey's between the
cutscenes and the gameplay the way that
the mechanics feed into the level design
and vice versa I think it's just all
like of a piece in a great way and
that's why it is number seven on our top
10 list as I said earlier each week
daily up till this number xx we will be
announcing another games so tomorrow
will be number six and then next week we
will start off with number five then go
four and then a mega stream 3 to 1 if
you want to catch up on all that other
stuff please do so go look at the other
games we've announced and if you want to
stick around right now
don't turn this stream off we're gonna
be playing Wolfenstein to the new
Colossus this is where I have to give a
spoiler warning a little bit I'm will
try our best not to spoil anything major
but we do want to play one of the cooler
parts of the game so yeah where are we
yeah we're in New Orleans um which is
pretty much in ruins and there's a New
Orleans resistance group that you're
trying to find
yes that's like a common thread in the
game right trying to your recruiting
wake up and you know all the resistance
cells but yeah Black Panthers but
whatever I forget what coop Orton's
group is called yeah they're they're
like they're almost like beatnik in a
way and yeah as you can see this is with
the constrictor harness contractions
this is a little bit after halfway
through the game and so we're gonna be
probably tackling this a little more
stealthy because that's the perks that I
have unlocked on this safe I have to
play a little differently than I'm used
to but you know that's the beauty of
this game is there's so many different
ways to play and I mean like if you trip
an alarm you can just go I'm probably
gonna go guns blazing and
like five minutes yeah I had so much fun
doing stealth in this game well yeah
fun's a weird word I found it very
satisfying because it was like I was
being so careful and exploiting their
weaknesses and I have a silencer on as
you can see here sauce around the pistol
I mean they figured it out in new order
but just have introducing those officers
into the mix like code for them first or
they could set off the alarm it makes
you sometimes like sneak around other
characters to get to them right and then
as you would solve their for those who
are watching the gameplay not just
listening the constructor harness hasn't
a bit like has a side bonus I didn't
even see this when I play this level it
has like a bonus where time slows down
when enemies spot you know which is yeah
yeah which is super helpful and that's
probably why I liked self so much and I
didn't even know that that was the case
until I had selected it cuz like they
all have those miners not miner but they
have those side bonuses and then that
started happening and I thought it was
just because of something that happened
in the story like halfway through and I
was like oh Vijay can do this now but
like some Nick was like no I don't have
that ability yeah Nick you did the
bulrush one I did the bulrush one which
was literally so so a ramshackle Ram
shadows I think one of the most useful
things is the armor-piercing rounds for
this gun you can just shred because like
everybody has like mechanical on Earth's
oh and then I'm doing the in the safe
it's the Wyatt timeline so rather than
the lazer Kraftwerk which is a returning
gun from new order it has like a you
should shoot explosive charges with it
yeah I can break that out yes there's
two different guns depending on the
timeline you choose and you can select
that beginning of the game which is
worth noting it doesn't continue you're
safe as far as I know yeah I've been
meaning to go back and play the Ferguson
online yes I played wide as well and I
think that's interesting that in the
past games it was you know like oh my
only reason to go back and play this
game again is to see the other timeline
but that's not really the case for this
game because of how much postgame
content there is yeah yeah this so this
is like about maybe a little more than
halfway through the game I'd say yeah
it's not more than that but yeah this is
the gun I upgraded the most I know Joey
was playing a lot but the armor-piercing
rounds are just like that's the first
thing you should get a fun can we um I
didn't do a wield it all because I I'm
just like not Corden and it coordinated
enough to do a wheels oh yeah that's
quick reload as well yeah I don't know I
love the feedback you get when you hit
enemies yeah and just feel like you're
actually hitting him in the knee when
you see him recoil or anything like that
residue before it was like the first
game I've never doing that really well
hmm well it's not broadcast anymore so
you killed whatever officer yeah we're
gonna need this
yeah that's there were a lot of new like
two-handed weapons that were introduced
in this game as well hmm versus new
order I think how many were in new order
that we're like two handed oh not that
many yeah I don't really remember either
the heavy weapons that you can't ask
that aren't in your inventory I barely
use that grenade launcher that you get
from Wyatt burden on his playthrough
yeah I use that a ton I love that I
would like it I forgot I had it
yeah so I fought this and they're going
pretty oh wow
I'll damage him and then I go down okay
I'm sorry I tried to just sneak past
them and i i i did this section so many
times because I was like so determined
not to like trigger that giant cat thing
the West I don't know it's a happened
yeah it's like Holland it's whatever um
I think one of the most like interesting
things about this game was like talking
to Cali about how she Lee completed some
of the major like story elements where
it was you know I had gone whoa guns
blazing like this versus Cali had
completely snuck by some of these major
enemies and I was like I can't defeat
this giant robot it was like oh how did
you do it and I was like I just ran the
point in Roswell where there was a
pretty tough fight and I ended up just
circumventing cuz I didn't want to try
it for this time the yeah the Roswell
section is super hard and that's at the
beginning like that's one of the
difficulty spikes I was talking about
like it's just like oh okay I guess
we're in the [ __ ] now yeah early on yeah
yeah there's a there's a lion Bobby
you see what he said he said you mess
with an Aryan you die holy [ __ ]
I said I was gonna die on the stream but
I did die yes true what difficulty are
we on I don't think I changed it because
we reloaded the save though oops I am
playing on my higher difficulty we were
gonna cheat and put the difficulty lower
but just play this when you're fine
you're fine you're doing you're doing it
as good as you could be but you're doing
I'm gonna cheat now
yeah the tool the game gives you I
wanted to fight him but now he just says
cheat anyway let's fight our
reassurances give a high bang bang I
really thought there were gonna be more
Gators in there I don't think there are
at least let's let's not find out and
then just like that like the actual look
set pieces here or you see like walking
through this section you hear people
screaming because the soldiers are going
through and like getting people out of
the buildings yeah I'm sorry I mean I
see that but I'm not gonna kill you
sorry I'm you've already been you know
what this is mo this is true to the
experience of playing this game well
it's just we did want to go and like
play a really deep part of the game that
would have been more spoilery but that I
don't know if we can say did we say we
were gonna talk about some spoilery
stuff yeah we forget a spoiler warning
yeah if you don't want someone else oh I
feel bad for Peter sorry Peter
wow I can't hear you like in new order
when you go off planet there's another
moment where you leave moment
there's another level yeah where you
leave this planet and you go to another
planet another planet
yeah but Nazi came from the moon that
Venus mission awesome the Venus mission
is really cool
I remember in new order when you go to
the moon I was like are you kidding me
right now like I was not expecting that
at all and and like we won't spoil any
like story stuff on Venus I guess
because there's some important stuff but
like that is a women missions yeah and
that's what we wanted to plan stream but
that it's like it had hard heavy heavy
heavy
I don't think I don't think we could get
to it without getting through the
cutscene also because I think that's
where my save is yeah and that cutscene
you don't want someone like us chatting
over the top yeah you're gonna want to
sit down put on headphones and like
really enjoy it that cutscene gave me
like a minor panic attack and for like
like it that's how it was just a lot
yeah it's good I'd take a break well
that goes our that's not the game's
fault that's like I have my stuff you
know and those are also like the moments
that you're like wow like I really
didn't see the story going like this off
the rails yeah you're like oh my god how
much further it's like you should you
should really believe the game at that
point that it's gonna go off the rails
but even then you're like I didn't think
it's gonna go this off the rails
yeah after a while you just kind of like
you in any other game you'd be just
sensitized after they do it once but
then they keep a man
you just keep upping like the the shock
value and you're like oh my god we're
doing better but even then like I
wouldn't just say it's shock value like
I think there's a lot of narrative
substance to it yeah like it's not just
there to be shocking which i think is an
important distinction
[Music]
I'm so in love with the way the guns
look in this game uh-huh
we call it like that industrial kind of
design it's the that's another thing is
like oh go ahead no please I was gonna
say the the industrial designs of the
when you're in like an actual like Nazi
made ship or something like that like
we're in New Orleans right now so it's
gonna look burned out and like you can
see the effects of the occupation but in
like earlier when we in that Nazi
building like just the utilitarian
industrial designs of it all but with
like huge red like tapestries is just
the it's a very thoughtful design I
really like like it we were also talking
kind of before the stream how in this
game a lot of like when you play Call of
Duty you know when your health is like
starting to really dip mm-hmm in this
game you can find yourself at like 2
percent health in like two seconds be
like oh oh yes like already and then got
a book in here on yeah I would I would
say like sometimes that enjoyed me but I
think overall I it was it was my fault
but right yeah it is a punishing game
we're groovin we're groovin I have no
ammo but we're groovin do you know what
I am oh well for what I want to use
oh no I pick some up your place it's
hard to stream in alongside to you you
know you're playing it's flooded school
bus simulator fire warning shot
they're so scary got him there we go
yeah yeah it was terrifying peed a
little
alright yeah you want to go there yes -
number two - up gee this is kind of a
new experience for me as well because I
didn't play Starfleet you want you could
probably overcharge your health right
now and then go up because there's dudes
on the second floor overturned your
health is electing meth or something
thank you you just take more health and
it slowly drains so you can get up to
like 200 or something overcharge and
then there's a perk associated with
overcharging you asking what the lore
behind it is
I mean methyl is the thing they almost
ruined soldiers back 70 if I had the RAM
shackles this wall would be something
that I could go
yeah and a lot of the Third Reich
what a glorious hole that is shooting
but I know I mean they're evil don't
make it work bad dogs are born they're
made
oh my Nazis and yeah nearly sneaked into
that room for here can you not oh you
have no he has my I don't think so
constrict up that's how I was navigating
next one oh I did it
oh I would sneak oh god I would sneak
around
hello and welcome shotgun in narrow
hallways
[Music]
this is an inadvertent army of Darkness
reference yeah that was the first
r-rated movie I ever saw no kidding yeah
what was the reference clean-up on aisle
five
I don't know ever exactly what no he
says something like that when the witch
comes to the best Mart yeah I really
like evil dish yeah God like that's not
good yeah a lot of this game is just
running those dudes will drop armor yeah
you walked over it and picked it up so
specials do feel weaker later on the
game yeah I barely use the machine
pistol yeah I know gently Curley liked
it I think yeah you got me all your give
me all your gifts yes thank you
hey how are you understand what happened
oh I gotta turn the power of thought
right oh yeah power on you gotta kill
this other dude those other come closer
getting closer
he's down sir yeah right under you oh
well okay
idiot didn't see me I guess I'll go kill
him they're gonna keep coming right you
don't kill the officer hello hello Finch
Dean there is something that maybe I
didn't appreciate as much as I should
have
yes I know it's kind of like an integral
part of the game is all the kind of
articles and like newspaper edits and
all those things that are hidden
throughout the map and letters from
people I worry they read as many as I
could go kill the officer yeah you
should like to find them there's so many
like hidden items I'm not a big reader
[Laughter]
are you trying to figure out an eloquent
way to put it I very much I don't do a
lot of reading yes that means you
literally couldn't read words sometimes
it's like you know there's just so many
cool things to find in this map but I
just I would rather just run around and
kill things Nick I love you so much I
guarantee that there are people in the
chat right now that are probably
sky knows what's up readings for suckers
crying to Nick's point though Moby Dick
for me to next point you there's a
there's a vent you can crawl through
there's a good catch hold you inspect
speaking of read yes yeah that example
is actually really good the example of
like the Klan endorsing the Reich I
think one of the strongest things guys
totally [ __ ] the strongest dances this
game takes is isn't being like oh yeah
the clans having a great time like and a
lot of that is evidence and what you've
evident in what you can read the note in
the barn that's pretty much just satire
about America today
yeah there's almost of them are but like
that one specifically and there was a
lot of that in the new order to like
there was one where it was basically
like oh the it was like a German
newspaper saying we had to nuke
Manhattan because think of all the
soldiers who would have died if we did
invaded it yeah and I was like yeah yeah
and I mean they really don't hold back
on that stuff and yeah so - Nick points
there's a lot of value and just like
stopping when you have a moment when
you're not gonna die to check those
things out and and see what you can
learn about the world they're building I
believe in you you know I go kill the
officer alright so cool
Wow back on that you know it's trying to
prove a point I think what oh yeah yeah
all right where is he he's full you're
going in the wrong okay good you're
going right direction
yeah getting closer
nope you are really supercharged we're
supercharged there is no that's not him
just kidding
this [ __ ] is this dude I remember this
root like the officer being really hard
to find in here I had a lot of junk
there up top or downstairs I think God
something without sound I came here on
her behind me oh this is so stressful
yeah the fate of the nation is on your
shoulders basement
there was health right next to you well
there was where I saw the icon there yes
this is a little difficult please find
that officer right now you're like a
really stressing might get okay kill him
all right now find the officer they're
growing he's he's behind you now
I think he's upstairs mean yeah he is
but like you're this direction right yes
right right right right are we hot uh
he's like directly above you go upstairs
one more yeah yeah yeah oh that was like
climactic oh well hell yeah still kill
him now are you please Mike so please
right now the powers are now as I like
to say now we're cooking with gas
literally cuz you have to refuel your
yeah
no I'm not joking of any choice let's
break that baby out yeah the diesel
craft it's actually used this a lot
against the more heavily armored enemies
if Nick was an esports pro from Germany
that would be his handle died I've died
three times now I don't think I would
cut it in the eSports world but that
would be a cool name
there's that man here he comes shai hit
him with a diesel yeah remember he's
gonna launch himself at I cover him and
then what do I get Nate with I think
rubber boy detonates and no you're it
detonates with like LTE or something
like that I forget he did I don't think
so no you don't think so he's dead huh
yeah he would be up I should not be yeah
you should switch your he's like
handhelds grenade launcher with a little
wrist rocket yeah yeah that one is the
who's gonna try to sitcom wait look at
it go again
the Kampf no calm peaceful bang whoa so
I have it set so when you shoot it it
detonates on impact
oh yeah I didn't use oh you know what I
upgraded that later in the game I think
I think this save I don't have as I'd
upgraded yeah I'm much more of like I
tend to use assault rifles more in in
like any shooter so that's just the one
I went with and it's also the most
useful
yes
all right now I'm actually natural ready
so go downstairs this stuff really quick
and recharge the old rabbit diesel craft
also known as my eSports name it's Mike
all right cool oh she discussed a lot
what are you doing here okay no turn
turn around completely left yeah okay
now turn to your right a little bit
that's great
there's a downstairs see that and you
but yeah you got a hit Jesse this I mean
put like they do use a crap thing shoes
put the diesel craft thing on it and
then leave and then detonate it
we're just saw sakra nade and then run
or toss a grenade okay ready run oh
thank goodness I was now what and
Guggenheim I think you crawl into the
pipe literally yeah oh really no no I'm
sorry Bloo you there's a yeah oh okay
see this is all different I never went
down here are you sure yep yes there's
back there there's stairs the TV in here
is kind of dark these aren't the same
stair oh they're not I experiencing your
okay this part has a hound and here we
go let's finish this fight and I'll call
it a stream yes don't screw up I'm gonna
go No
well well I think you killed him I don't
think that I think we're gonna heard a
big explosion let's say oh no he's very
much alive
shoot him you know what the beauty of
this is that I can totally skip this now
what now go back all right jet stream
was a spike could be right different
yeah yeah kill chop off their legs cause
Craig just keep letting him crying F we
gonna die well that's the beauty of like
the different places like you can
totally just know I could skip that
battle I just did that whole battle is
real hard I don't think you're
illiterate belly yet to go back in
all I wanted to yeah finish tonight all
right all right I just proposed him with
that your armor piercing how is it Peter
is having a good day delirious
unfortunately we only gonna like stay
awake and see Star Wars later Wow that's
today
I have a 1 a.m. showing yeah mine's at
11:00 reload now three and then get home
at four and then wake up three hours
later for our number six game tomorrow
armor-piercing rounds or why couldn't
you get up this he is biting my legs
yeah is there any health no I don't
think there's any healthier armor armor
and he might have deer dropped someone I
killed him yeah yeah you got some yeah
yeah we did oh my god I can't imagine
what the counts are saying this good
sucks huh probably should have played
this game a little bit before the stream
in a while still my favourite game will
use I see that's the stream my friend
sweet dream those that was Wolfenstein
two new Colossus our number seven of the
year so number ten was near automata
number nine was what remains of Edith
Finch I said it correctly that time
number eight was hell blade sending with
sacrifice we now say yesterday and today
was Wolfenstein - and tomorrow we are
going to announce just kidding
number six will be announced tomorrow
same time 10:00 a.m. Pacific so you can
go I'll have a different one no I'll try
to but you can go catch up on all that
stuff on GameSpot or on YouTube after
the fact and thanks so much for joining
see you tomorrow
[Music]